[Musica]
buonasera voglio raccontarvi la storia
del sogno di un'altra scuola la scuola
penny wirton per l'insegnamento
dell'italiano agli immigrati
come è nata questa questa scuola come è
nata l'idea di rifondarla devo tornare
indietro il momento in cui ero bambino
avrà avuto circa otto anni in romagna
chiesi a mia nonna cosa fosse l'inferno
questa donna che non aveva nemmeno
studiato mi disse una cosa che mi è
rimasta dentro guarda immagini di dover
raccogliere da terra delle cartacce
sporche e metterle in una scatola senza
fondo che non si riempie mai una
maledizione
quello sarà l'inferno allora io
probabilmente sono rimasto sconcertato
un po triste
allora lei aggiunse forse per consolarmi
un'altra frase decisiva
guarda che se tu e rado ti comporterai
così con gli esseri umani non andrai
all'inferno andrai in paradiso cosa
voleva dire questo credere che tutti gli
incontri umani che noi realizziamo
possano essere a fondo perduto proprio
come come quelle cartacee che avremmo
dovuto raccogliere da terra e mettere in
questo in questa scatola senza fondo
pensare non al risultato che noi
potremmo tenere ma avere fede
nell'azione che stiamo realizzando
se tu pensi soltanto al risultato rischi
di restare deluso non devi essere
schiavo di questo risultato che potrai
avere divenire fede in quello che stai
realizzando ecco naturalmente da bambino
non potevo credere al senso di questa
cosa negli anni ocre sono cresciuto sono
diventato insegnante e scrittore
ho lavorato 30 anni negli istituti
professionali per l'industria e
l'artigianato di fronte ragazzi che
davvero dopo dieci minuti perdevano
attenzione e quindi sono stato abituato
a recuperarli attirò a trovare delle
risorse il loro che la scuola non
riusciva a realizzare e quindi per fare
questo naturalmente ho dovuto lavorare
anche dentro me stesso capire da dove
venivo io mia madre che rischiò di
morire durante la seconda guerra
mondiale in seguito alla fucilazione di
mio nonno un partigiano della 36esima
brigata garibaldi alessandro bianconcini
che venne mio nonno fucilato dai nazisti
mia madre a 17 anni
catturata dai fascisti consegnate
tedeschi messa su un treno che l'avrebbe
condotta nei lager riuscì a fuggire
mi amate a 17 anni alla stazione di
udine e sale non fosse riuscito a
fuggire probabilmente né io né il mio
fratello saremmo mai nati mio padre un
figlio illegittimo che non conobbe mai
il suo padre un bambino abbandonato
senza punti di riferimento
quando io chiedevo ai miei genitori ma
come avete fatto a sopravvivere
nell'italia del dopoguerra loro mi
rispondevano in modo insufficiente e
inadeguato per me quindi ho sentito da
piccolo la mancanza delle parole sono
stato anch'io in fondo a ben pensarci un
ragazzo di barbiana come quei bambini ai
quali si rivolgeva a don lorenzo milani
quando venne confinato in quell eremo
ecclesiastico appunto nell'appennino
proprio don lorenzo milani e ho dedicato
il mio ultimo libro intitolato l'uomo
del futuro e credo proprio adonia da don
lorenzo milani in fondo ho pensato nel
momento in cui sono entrato per la prima
volta in un'aula scolastica e lì in quel
momento che ho capito davvero di essere
dentro lo spazio magnetico capire che
veramente dovevo parlare con i miei
fantasmi interiori prima ancora che con
gli adolescenti difficili con i quali
avevo quotidianamente a che fare
e il momento in cui sono andato la città
dei ragazzi è stato per me è molto
importante la città dei ragazzi una
struttura creata da monsignor carole
bing dopo la seconda guerra mondiale
per accogliere i bambini abbandonati gli
sciuscià che non avevano più i punti di
riferimento dei genitori è lì che ho
conosciuto omar faris calik francisca
ho conosciuto questi ragazzi minorenni
non accompagnati da lì sono nati alcuni
miei libri uno intitolato proprio la
città dei ragazzi in cui racconta un
viaggio in marocco a vedere da dove
erano partiti o mare farissi miei
studenti un altro in gambia in africa
dove riaccompagnato cali che il quale
non sapeva se sua mamma fosse viva o
morta
nato in sierra leone costretto a fuggire
l'abbiamo qualche modo recuperato gli ho
messo io la mano diciamo sulla sua mano
per fargli vedere come si fa a scrivere
lui analfabeta della lingua madre
quindi non aveva mai tenuto una penna in
mano li ho scritto un altro libro vita
di vita in cui appunto il viaggio di
ritorno che quando il momento in cui
questa mamma l'abbiamo davvero
rocambolescamente ritrovata in gambia
lui ha voluto che il suo professore
d'italiano io andasse a conoscerla e
alla città di ragazzi che ho pensato
insieme a mia moglie anna lou cerenzia
chiesa diciamo come me e insegnante
insoddisfatte irrequieta
non contenta della scuola così come oggi
entrare in classe spiegare il programma
una lezione frontale come questo che sto
facendo adesso io lo voi e mettere il
voto no non può essere soltanto questo
la scuola a scuola deve essere qualcosa
di diverso
intanto deve essere un incrocio di
sguardi di cui prendersi cura
perché il professore il responsabile
dello sguardo altrui
esattamente come diceva dostoevskij nel
momento in cui affermava una
responsabilità che non poteva essere
soltanto giuridica non poteva essere
soltanto sociale non poteva essere
soltanto morale
tu ti devi prendere in carico lo sguardo
delle persone che ha di fronte se
facessimo così tutti noi forse
riusciremo a cambiare le persone non
certo il mondo che è impossibile ma le
persone si una perona 1 a 1
lì nasce la scuola penny wirton che
prende il nome
il titolo dal titolo di un romanzo di
silvio d'arzo grande scrittore italiano
il quale scrisse un libro intitolato
penny wirton e sua madre protagonista un
bambino abbandonato che non conobbe mai
suo padre sia io che mia moglie ci siamo
laureati su silvio d'arzo abbiamo quindi
deciso di chiamare così la scuola penny
wirton per l'insegnamento dell'italiano
gli immigrati concepita nel sogno di don
lorenzo milani 1 a 1 quindi senza classe
senza voti senza registi senza
burocrazie
ecco questo è il sogno della nostra
scuola penny wirton che è nata a roma
centinaia di volontari che lavorano
gratis e quindi si sottraggono in
qualche modo si distinguono rispetto al
nostro tempo nostra un tempo retributivo
io ti do
e tu mi dai no noi diamo a prescindere
da quello che possiamo ottenere visto
che non abbiamo dimensione finanziaria e
quindi crediamo nell'azione che stiamo
facendo esattamente come diceva mia
nonna rosina patullo alla quale in fondo
ci ricolleghiamo l'idea della benetton
nasce proprio nel momento in cui ho
capito che avremmo potuto coinvolgere
anche i nostri figli
anche i nostri ragazzi anche i nostri
oceani una volta lo ho capito proprio la
città dei ragazzi quando avevo un
ragazzo giulio giulio bocciato in prima
superiore al liceo scientifico
ribocciato all'istituto nautico per la
seconda volta si è descritto all
istituto carlo cattaneo di roma e stava
per essere bocciato anche da noi e io
cercavo di recuperarlo a questo ragazzo
lo vedevo che era intelligente che era
che aveva delle doti inaspettate
scriveva in un modo particolare aveva
una sensibilità sintattica che nessuno
poteva avergli insegnato esattamente
come gli occhi azzurri
voglio dire quelle doti genetiche no e
allora perché lo bocciavano tutti allora
un giorno a ricreazione l'ho chiamato e
mi sono giocato tutto in quel momento
gli ho detto giulio ma perché tu non
vieni con me oggi pomeriggio appena
uscito da scuola ad insegnare l'italiano
agli immigrati alla penny wirton mi ha
guardato all'inizio un po smarrito ma
perché non glielo chiedi a giorgio che
ha 8 in italiano questa cosa ma perché
io non glielo chiedi a marco che va bene
a scuola dicono perché loro non hanno
bisogno di me sei tu che se tu adesso mi
direi di sì insomma mi darà una risposta
importante
lui ha detto guarda non ti dico la
risposta te lo dirò il giorno dopo il
pomeriggio sono stato a pensare cosa
avrebbe detto giulio proprio lui il
bocciato l'indisciplinato e ribelle
rabbioso l'irrequieto cosa mi avrebbe
detto il giorno dopo è venuto mi ha
detto guarda voglio fare questa prova a
venire da voi è venuto un anno intero
giulio tutti i martedì pomeriggio ad
insegnare gratuitamente l'italiano
arusha dura o mara faris lo stesso
ragazzo bocciato lo stesso ragazzo
scartato dal sistema valutativo che lui
stesso in primo luogo rifiutava si è
messo seduto di fronte ai suoi coetani
immigrati 16 17 anni le tate di questi
terroristi di barcellona
un adolescente lasciato da solo è a
rischio
noi dobbiamo prenderci cura di questi
cura di questi ragazzi io vedere giulio
di fronte a loro
a questo a questo suo coetaneo lui così
ho capito che la scuola penny wirton
poteva avere un futuro
siamo riusciti tanti in questi anni
eravamo io mia moglie 22 professoresse
volenterose siamo circa 2 300 persone
soltanto a roma 30 sedi in tutta italia
dalla sicilia fino al friuli persone che
si mettono in gioco che entrano in
azione che creano delle postazioni
vitalistiche che attraggono energie in
questo paese
che è molto ma molto più bello di quello
che ci fa vedere la televisione tutti i
giorni io scopro tutti i giorni persone
nuove persone con risorse speciali
persone che entrano in azione in questa
in questa azione didattica 1 1 abbiamo
scritto un libro intitolato italiani
anche noi io mia moglie abbiamo voluto
organizzare anche uno strumento
didattico con due volumi uno rosso e uno
blu pubblicati dal margine di trento
usiamo questa questa questo strumento
didattico insieme ad altri ad altri
sistemi di ludo didattica parole
colorate serpentoni schemi e vi assicuro
che nel momento in cui trovi questi
ragazzi che arrivano e arrivano
volenterosi capisci che quello è il
compenso che tu cercare ieri ho fatto un
incontro più a cortina questo punto
conosciuto alcune professoresse di
limana che hanno fondato una penny
wirton qui non lontano da qui e mi hanno
raccontato la storia di un ragazzo un
ragazzo se ne senegalese che si è fatto
a piedi da belluno fino a limana per
diciamo avere questa lezione che lui
aveva capito era una lezione speciale
una lezione è preziosa
una lezione di cui lui poteva fruire in
modo assolutamente gratuito tutto per
lui sarebbe stata l'insegnante che non
era pagata che non era distribuita che
stava lì soltanto per per lui
e allora si faceva a piedi ma questo a
questo percorso
mi è sembrata diciamo la testimonianza
straordinaria di quello che potrebbe
essere che potrebbe diventare il nostro
mondo
noi come italiani abbiamo una
responsabilità storica fondamentale
importante dobbiamo metterci alla testa
dell'europa perché non siamo soltanto la
frontiera meridionale in senso
geografico ma dovremmo e potremmo essere
il testimone dell'europa visto che da
noi è nato il rinascimento da noi è nato
urbanesimo e non possiamo pensare che a
dettarci gli ordini siano degli oscuri
burocrati di main street
noi che siamo stati
i figli spirituali di francesco petrarca
vi ringrazio buonasera
[Applauso]